[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIMON WARDLEY: Hello.
Hello.
Yay.
It's the final session
of the conference.
Well done for getting this far.
My name is Simon Wardley.
I'm going to talk to you about
crossing the river by feeling
the stones.
Couple of warnings
before I start.
I'm going to go through an awful
lot and we've only got an hour.
So I've done a quick graph.
Level of audience pain,
that's you, against the number
of slides given in an
hour's presentation.
There's a safe limit
of around about 40.
Since I like to experiment,
I'll be using 362.
So this is going to go
really, really quickly.
So save that-- run away, OK.
The other thing is, I'm
going to talk about strategy.
I don't like the subject much.
I normally expect these
people to turn up and tell me,
agile all the things,
or whatever's popular.
These people-- I
mean consultants.
Things like IoT everything,
AI everything, et cetera.
Or my favorite is
earlobes everything.
This is from the
"Harvard Business
Review," November 2011.
"How Earlobes Can Signify
Leadership Potential."
It's phrenology of
management, so it's
really important for executives
to have the right size
earlobes.
So I'm going to
talk about strategy
from my own personal perspective
when I was CEO of a software
company called Fotango.
We'd been bought out by Canon.
We built a number of different
services, online photo
services, several
million users, et cetera.
And we were doing
fine, revenue all good,
and we were profitable.
But we had a problem
and the problem was me.
Because rather than being
a chessmaster of strategy
like CEO, I was making
it up as I went along.
I was a fake CEO.
It was all-- well, I
had all those things
like vision statements.
"Our strategy is
customer focused.
We will lead an innovative
effort of the market
through our use of agile
techniques and open source."
And that sounded good,
except for I'd pinched it
from someone else
because I really
had no clue what I was doing.
But what I did do is I
used to go around listening
to other CEOs talk
about strategy
and I started to
record the words
they said, looking for
what I call Business Level
Abstractions of a Healthy
Strategy, or BLAHS, for short.
And I do this every
couple of years
and this is my recent
set of common BLAHS
that people talk about.
Things like digital
business, big data,
disruptive, innovative,
collaborative, competitive,
advantage, ecosystem, open
source, et cetera, et cetera.
And then, what I normally
do is get all these strategy
documents, pile them together,
and generate a Blah template.
"Our strategy is Blah.
We will lead a Blah
effort of the market
through use of Blah and
Blah to build a Blah."
And then I combine the
Blahs and the Blah template
and also generate a whole
bunch of different strategies
at random.
So I thought I'd
go through some.
Strategy number one,
total random gibberish.
"Our strategy is
customer focused.
We will lead a disruptive
effort of the market
through our use of innovative
social media and big data
to build a collaborative
cloud based ecosystem."
Strategy two, again,
total gibberish.
"Our strategy is innovative
digital business.
We will lead a growth
effort of the market
through our use of customer
focused competitive advantage."
You get the thing.
And then I send them
around to people
and I normally get responses
of three basic types.
"This is more or less
the exact wording
from our business plan."
"I've seen two of
these used already."
And my favorite is,
"Are you for hire?"
By the way, a friend of mine
has put this all online.
This is strategy as a service.
So if you ever need a
strategy, just type in the URL.
This is the one I did earlier.
Well, I did it yesterday.
You just type In the URL.
If you don't like it,
just press refresh.
"Our strategy is collaborative.
We will lead an open
effort of the market
through our use of big
data and social media."
Anyway, so there
I was in 2005, CEO
of this company, not knowing
a clue of what I was doing.
I was like, oh, oh, dear.
What shall I do?
So I went back to basics.
Sun Tzu.
Anybody know what Sun Tzu wrote?
"Art of War," fantastic.
Sun Tzu talked
about five factors
that mattered in competition.
One, understand your purpose,
your moral imperative.
Two, understand the landscape
that you're competing in.
Three, the climactic patterns
that impact that landscape.
Four, your doctrine,
and then you're
into leadership, which is
context-specific gameplay.
Then I came across John Boyd.
Anybody know what
John Boyd wrote?
AUDIENCE: OODA.
SIMON WARDLEY: OODA.
OODA loops.
A US Air Force pilot.
John talked about,
you have the game.
The first thing you do is
observe the environment,
so that's the landscape
and the climatic patterns.
You orientate around the game.
And then you decide
what you're going to do.
That's the
context-specific play.
And then you act.
Now often, people will
say, well strategy's
all about the importance of why.
Well, that's fair enough,
but there are two whys.
There's the why of
purpose, as in, I
want to be the best
online photo service.
And the why of movement,
as in, why do I
make this move over that move?
So if you think about
a game of chess,
you've got the why of purpose,
which is to win the game,
and then you've got
why of movement.
Should I move that piece or
should I move that piece?
And it's through movement
that we do learning.
So we move that piece, it gives
us a tiny bit of advantage,
not much of a great deal.
But if we move that
piece, checkmate, you see?
So much better.
So if I go back to
Fotango, I had my purpose,
online photo service.
Here we are, 2005,
very profitable.
The next bit is, how do I
understand the landscape?
How do I observe
the environment?
This led me into a topic known
as situational awareness.
And to explain this, I'm
going to use three examples.
Vikings, chess,
and Themistocles.
Vikings, a very fearsome race.
The way Vikings did navigation
is they used stories.
Things like, "From Hernam,
head due west towards Hvarf,
and you will have sailed
north of Hjaltland,
so that you just glimpse
it in clear weather."
That, actually, is just that.
A much simpler translation.
But the question
I have to you is,
what would you use to navigate?
A visual map or a verbal story?
What do you think?
Map?
Story?
AUDIENCE: Story.
SIMON WARDLEY: Story.
Map.
A map.
OK.
What do we use in business?
AUDIENCE: Stories.
SIMON WARDLEY: Stories.
Super.
Right.
Excellent.
The next example is chess world.
I want you to imagine
you live in a world
where everybody plays chess, but
no one's ever seen the board.
All you've ever seen are
these characters on a screen.
And you play the
game very simply.
You press a button,
your opponent counters,
you press a button,
they counter.
And the game goes on for
ages until somebody wins
or it's a draw.
Now, what will
happen is people will
take these sequences of many
games and feed them into their,
I don't know, big data
systems and come up
with magic secrets of success.
So if you press queen,
I should respond
with king, pawn, or whatever.
And we'll write articles about
that, a bit like earlobes.
Then what will happen is you
will play a game of chess
against somebody who will
see something truly magical,
the board, but you
won't know this.
And so you'll press a
piece and they'll counter.
And you'll press a piece
and they'll counter
and you'll have lost.
And your first--
you'll be there,
what the fiddlesticks
happened there?
All right.
The first thing
you're going to do
is scribble down that
sequence as though it's
some sort of magic
sequence which you're
going to try and use yourself.
And you'll still lose.
And then you'll start
thinking, well, maybe it's
the speed at which they
pressed the button.
Then you'll start
going, is it cultural?
They're a happy sort of person.
Maybe that's why they beat me.
They beat you because
you exist in a low level
situational awareness
environment.
So what would you use
to learn, by the way?
Secrets of success?
Or context specific game play?
What do you think?
[INAUDIBLE]
SIMON WARDLEY: Excellent.
What do you think
we use in business?
AUDIENCE: Secrets of success.
SIMON WARDLEY:
Secrets of success.
Excellent.
Super.
Right.
The next example
is Themistocles,
ancient politician,
Greek general.
Had a problem.
The Persians were invading.
Had choices.
Defend around Athens,
defend around Thebes.
What he decided to
do was to block off
the Straits of Artemisium,
force the Persians
along the coastal road into
Thermopylae, narrow pass,
small number of troops defend
against a larger force.
So about 170,000 Persians, 4,000
Greeks, including 300 Spartans.
Fabulous.
So I want you to imagine you're
a member of the Athenian army,
so part of the Greek states.
It's the eve of battle.
Themistocles is in front of you.
He's giving you purpose,
a moral imperative.
We must defeat the Persians.
And then he says to you, I
don't understand the landscape.
I don't understand
the environment.
I have no map.
But have no fear, for I
have created a SWOP diagram.
[LAUGHTER]
Strengths.
A well trained Spartan army,
a high level of motivation
not to become a Persian slave.
Weaknesses.
The Ephors might stop
the Spartans turning up.
Sorry, a truckload of
Persians are turning up.
Opportunities.
Get rid of the Persians,
get rid of the Spartans.
We're Athenian, we
actually hate the Spartans.
Threats.
The Persians get rid
of us and the Oracle
says a really dodgy film might
be produced a few thousand
years later.
OK.
So what would you use to
communicate and determine
strategy in battle?
Position and movement
described by a map or some sort
of magic framework?
What would you use in business?
[LAUGHTER]
SIMON WARDLEY: Excellent.
[? CPAV, ?] right.
You're getting the point.
So here I've got chess,
here I've got alchemy.
Navigation, learning,
and strategy.
In chess, it's all
visual, contextspecific.
It's all about
position and movement.
It's what we call a high
level situational awareness
environment, a bit
like the military.
If you ask a general, why
did you bomb the hill?
They won't say, because I read
an article in "General Weekly"
that 67% of generals
bombard hills.
They won't tell you, because
it would make a good story.
Or that's what Uber would do.
But over here, this is alchemy.
This is all about
storytelling, secrets
of success, magic frameworks.
It's all low level situational
awareness environment.
And so that's where I
was as the fake CEO,
desperately hoping
that no one would
rumble that I didn't know what
on earth I was talking about.
Anyway, I explained this
to a couple of my peers
and they said, oh, don't worry,
it's all about execution.
Well that's interesting because
that's one of those memes,
"I'd rather have a
first-rate execution
and second-rate strategy."
I tend to like data, though.
So I went around looking--
I to 160 Silicon
Valley companies,
looked at their level
of strategic play,
situational awareness from low
to high, and the use of open--
as in open source,
open data, open
APIs-- as ways of
manipulating the market.
The bigger the bubbles, the
more companies in that group.
Now, if execution ruled,
these would be doing well.
If strategy ruled, those
would be doing well.
And that's what it
actually looks like.
Market cap changes over
a seven-year period,
positive, more negative.
It turns out both are important.
Strategy actually matters.
So Dimon's doctrine, as
Professor Martin said,
is about "as flawed
as it is popular,"
which is a bit of a shame.
So I would explain that to
people and they would go,
but we're successful, getting--
it was my fat cat getting
a little bit angry here.
Which is fair enough, if
you're fighting against others.
It's OK to be
hopeless at this stuff
as long as everybody else
is because then no one gains
an advantage.
And there's this
wonderful study by Fitza,
"Use of Variance Decomposition
in the Investigation of CEO
Effects," which basically
says those are no
different from random chance.
So you can just get
someone off the street.
At which point, people
get really angry at me.
We're not stupid!
Well, that's fair enough.
But there is a difference.
You don't have to
be daft to be blind.
So the Vikings themselves, they
didn't see the environment.
They had stories, it was
their way of communication.
They didn't use maps at all.
Doesn't mean they were daft.
And the difference
turns out to be maps.
But what do we mean by maps?
Well, maps have
certain characteristics
that are really important.
They are visual,
context-specific, battle
at hand.
You have the position of
pieces relative to some anchor.
In this case, a compass.
And you can see
consistent movement
and, obviously, you
have components.
It's the same with
the chessboard.
Visual, context-specific.
You have position
of pieces relative
to an anchor, the anchor
being the board itself,
and you have movement.
And that's what a map has.
So what did I have in business?
Well, I had systems
diagrams, network topologies,
which are not maps.
They don't have those
navigation characteristics.
Or I had things like this.
Business process maps, which
turn out not to be maps either.
In fact, I had loads
of diagrams which
call themselves
maps and didn't have
any of the
characteristics of a map.
So that was my problem, 2005.
How do I create a map?
So I took one of my
network topology diagrams.
I said, right, I need an anchor.
We're going to have
to start somewhere.
So I took the customer
and the user need.
That was my anchor
at the very top.
Great.
Now we need position.
Well, I had lots of components,
which were basically
in a chain of needs.
So things like, the customer
wanted print, print needed
a website, website needed
a platform, platform needed
compute, compute needed power.
So I could create
a chain of needs.
Now I've got position
and an anchor.
Good.
But I still have no movement.
Well, that's a problem.
Because if you look at
somebody like Nokia,
it was a paper mill,
plastics manufacturer,
telecommunications company,
something else today.
It's changing.
So I need to describe movement.
So I took power.
I thought, well, power.
We start off with a
Parthian Battery, 480 AD.
Somehow, we end up with utility
provision, 1886, Westinghouse,
Tesla.
So how do we go
from there to there?
My first idea was diffusion
curves, Everett Rogers's work,
made famous by Geoffrey Moore.
Have you heard of
"Crossing the Chasm"?
Yes?
So adoption over time.
Geoffrey Moore does it as
the non-cumulative form.
Everett Rogers, the original
work, is the s-curve shape.
Geoffrey, very valuably,
added this chasm,
the thing you have to jump
over, from the early market
to the mainstream market.
I thought, well, this is
going to be simple, isn't it?
Because what I'm
going to do is I'm
probably going to
get something up here
and we'll get custom
built examples,
and then probably
products and commodity.
And I just have to find
the right percentages
and, oh, that's wonderful.
That'll be easy.
Except for--
unfortunately, I like data.
So I looked at things like--
well, take this, the smartphone.
Right.
Who thinks the smartphone
is a commodity?
Hands up.
There's quite a few
of you who don't.
OK.
And what percentage
of people in the US
do you think have smartphones?
65%, 70%, 80%, 90%?
OK, fine.
Right.
Gold bars.
Who thinks gold bars
are a commodity?
Is there somebody
here who doesn't think
a gold bar is a commodity?
OK, fine.
What percentage of the
population have gold bars?
All right.
The problem is, a
whole bunch of stuff
wasn't commodity when 70%,
80% of the population had it.
But a whole bunch of things
were commodity when only 1%
of the population had it.
So I can't really use adoption
as a measure of change.
Turned out that things
appeared and would
evolve through multiple
diffusion curves
over different time frames and
different applicable markets.
So I can actually use adoption
or time to measure change.
So I was a bit
stymied at that point.
And then I noticed something.
When looking back through
the history of telephones--
this is diffusion of multiple
improving forms of telephones.
In the earlier
stages, I noticedS
we wrote manuals like this.
"The Telephone and
How to Use It."
How to hold it, how to
speak into it, et cetera.
And I thought, well, we
don't do that anymore.
And then I discovered
things like this.
"This room is equipped
with Edison Electric Light.
Do not attempt to
light with a match.
Simply turn key on
wall by the door."
And so I started to
look into publications.
And what happens is
something appears
and we have publications
talking about the wonder of it.
The wonder of radio.
Then that gets overtaken
by publications talking
about how to build something.
Building construction awareness,
how to build your own crystal
radio set.
Then that gets overtaken
by publications,
which talk about operation,
maintenance, and feature
differentiation.
And finally, you
get publications
which talk about use.
So things like the wonder of
radio, crystal radio sets,
how to build one, my
radio is better or worse
than your radio.
Followed by, here's
the radio times,
what's good on channel
whatever at 4 o'clock?
And so there was increasing
certainty about the thing.
So what I did was I took this
point, where the publication
types changed, went back
and looked and found
the applicable market,
then measured ubiquity
against the applicable
market against certainty,
that point of stability,
and discovered this pattern.
What happens is things
appear novel and new,
the genesis of new
acts like the first
ever telephone, the first
computer, the Z3, 1943,
the Parthian battery.
Then, through demand
and supply competition,
it evolves and you get
custom built examples.
Then you get products.
So computers, you got
things like the IBM 650.
Improving products,
rental services,
time-share, commodity
hardware, and eventually,
utility services.
And that is movement.
So I was able to
take my value chain,
flatten that evolution curve
at the bottom, add in movement,
and suddenly, I had a map.
Quick recap.
I started off as this
fake CEO, no clue
what I was doing
because I hadn't
gone to the right courses.
No one had taught me
how to do this stuff
so I had to invent my own way.
I realized I was
competing against others.
I was completely blind,
totally depending
upon stories, secrets of
success, and magic frameworks.
So I thought, well,
hang on a minute.
I want to be over here.
That means I need to understand,
A, that strategy's a cycle.
That I need to
observe the landscape,
learn about climatic
patterns, orientate around it,
and then get into
context-specific play.
Which means I need
to first understand
the landscape with a map.
A map needs an anchor, so
that was users and user needs.
I need position
relative to an anchor,
so that's my value chain.
I add in evolution.
I now have a map.
It is 2005.
And I went to other people
and said, look at this,
isn't it exciting?
And they went, so what?
Well, now I have a map.
I can start to observe
climatic impacts.
These are the roles
that influence the game.
The first one I noticed was
that everything evolves.
Due to supply and
demand competition,
it's all moving
from left to right.
The next one is the
characteristics change
as it evolves.
It starts off in this
uncharted space, where
it's chaotic, uncertain,
poorly understood, changing,
different, exciting, and
a source of future worth.
And over an unknown
amount of time,
it becomes industrialized,
ordered, standard, stable,
measured, dull, boring.
This is known as the Salaman
and Storey Innovation
Paradox of 2002.
So the next thing I noticed was
that, because characteristics
change, there's no such thing
as a one size fits all method.
Agile in-house was very
strong on the left,
very weak on the right compared
to things like Six Sigma, which
was all about reducing
deviation, and very weak
in the middle compared to
things like Lean Enterprise
because they're all focused on
learning and reducing waste.
So there's no such thing
as one size fits all.
Which was great,
because in 2002--
sorry, 2001, we'd gone
all Agile, as in XP.
And then by about 2003,
2004, we were discovering
it wasn't working everywhere.
So now, we--
2005, we understood why.
We also realized that our
purchasing methods were not
singular.
We needed time, material, VC
based here, outcome based here,
COTS and fixed, and utility.
That's good.
Then we learned another pattern.
As things evolved, they
became more efficient,
like electricity.
But that enables higher
order systems to appear.
Electricity enabling
computing, radio, television.
So if you think about
the nuts and bolts,
used to be a home
made cottage industry.
Then Maudslay introduced
the screw cutting lathe.
Suddenly, you get an explosion
in standard nuts and bolts
and suddenly, an
explosion in machinery.
And those higher order systems
create new sources of value
and new sources of worth.
So as electricity became a
utility, enabled television,
and television became
a new industry.
Of course, all this stuff
is uncertain on the left.
So you didn't know whether
the box in the corner showing
pictures was going to
be the future success
or whether it was the
refrigeration blanket.
Personally I would have
gone for the blanket,
but it turned out to be the box.
So things evolve, new things
appear, they evolve, they
enable new things to appear.
And so what you get is a line
of the present in a constant sea
of moving components.
And then you learn
more patterns.
That we have inertia to change
because of past success.
So if you take somebody
like Blockbuster, Netflix,
who was first with a website?
Blockbuster.
Right.
Who was first with
video ordering online?
Blockbuster, yay.
Who was first with experimenting
with streaming video online?
Blockbuster, yay.
Who went bankrupt?
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
So anybody who says, you
don't want to be uninnovative
like Blockbuster,
well, actually, they
pretty much out-innovated
most people.
Their problem-- do you know
what their problem was?
Late fees.
Hence the stores.
Late fees, they were
addicted to late fees.
For those of you
who don't remember,
you would get a video,
it's a cassette thing
which you'd get from the shop,
go home, forget to take it back
the next day, and get
charged a fortune.
So now we have some
basic patterns,
we can anticipate,
communicate, and challenge.
So I took my map of
online photo service,
I knew the computing platform
was evolving to a utility.
I knew that we would have
inertia to the change.
I knew that this would enable
higher order systems to appear
and that some of them were
new sources of value or worth
and we would get a new
line of the future.
So there we were,
sitting in the boardroom.
I had IT, I had business
development, finance,
operations, marketing.
We're all sitting around
discussing, around a map,
how our world is changing.
A bit like, in the
military, a marine
needs to call in air support.
They can use a map to do so.
You don't phone up--
oh, sorry, or call in on
a radio and get somebody
from air support, the Air Force.
And they turn around and say,
do you know how to fly a jet?
No.
Well, we can't support you then.
But interestingly, we
do that in business.
You may have noticed
everybody in IT thinks
everybody else should learn IT.
And everybody in finance
thinks everybody else
should learn finance.
And so we didn't
have that problem.
That was nice.
And then we learned
about weak signals.
Weak signals.
A friend of mine used to run
a hedge fund, greed is good,
all that sort of stuff.
They wanted to use
social networks
to look at where their
companies were possibly thinking
about acquiring others.
And I explained, that's
not the way you do it
because CEOs don't tend to
like each other on Facebook
or whatever, especially not
prior to an acquisition.
But what they do
like is private jets
and the tailplane
numbers are public and so
are the flight plans.
So what you can do is
just map the movement
of all the private jets,
looking for disturbances
in the pattern.
This was 2008.
They're very good at
leaking information.
Everything must be secret.
We jump into our jet
and we leak information
because it's all public.
Anyway, the point is,
you can use weak signals
with this stuff.
So we knew compute would
evolve to a utility.
We knew people
would have inertia.
We knew that would enable
higher order systems to appear.
And this sort of change is known
as a punctuated equilibrium.
It's a non-linear
form of change.
Now this is part
of a cycle known
as Peace, War, and Wonder.
It goes at both a local
and a macroeconomic scale.
What happens?
You get big vendors
in this space,
whatever it happens to be.
They all have inertia to
change because of past success.
New entrants, unencumbered by
a preexisting business model,
move in, like a
bookseller for hardware.
That causes an explosion
of higher order systems,
the wonder out of which
new industries form,
and of course, all
the people stuck
behind the inertia barriers,
they disappear off the cliff.
And this occurs at both a
local and a macro scale.
At the macro, we call them
ages, so Age of Electricity
didn't start with
the Parthian battery.
It started with
industrialization
of electricity preexisting
at Tesla and Westinghouse.
Same as the mechanical age--
Machine Age.
Didn't start with the
formation of nuts and bolts.
That was long before.
It started with
industrialization, that shift
from product to more commodity.
The point about this is, this
is the trigger, the shift
from product to commodity.
And that's based upon
that evolution curve,
which comes from this, which
comes from those publication
types.
So you can actually use the
publication types and variants
within them as a weak signal for
when these changes will occur.
And that's the last time I
did a weak signal analysis.
It's 2014, so it's
three years old.
And what you've got is big data
is just entering the war, 2015,
which basically means you've
got loads of big data product
vendors running around
saying we're the future.
You've got about 10 or 15
years before they're all
disappearing.
It's already moving
into utility space.
That's already happening.
Platform, we're in that space.
Center as a service,
a bit further away.
But anyway, that
comes from the data.
And the point about
this is you know
that these points
of industrialization
are approaching, so you
can at least plan for it.
A quick recap.
I wanted to be over
here, not over here.
I hadn't done an MBA.
This is obviously the stuff they
teach people at MBA's, but I
had to invent it because
I couldn't afford an MBA.
I started off with
the strategy cycle.
Understand, observe your
environment and landscape
climate, orientate
with doctrine,
then you're into leadership.
It's a cycle, it's
an iterative process.
Key for this is understanding
your landscape, your map.
It has some basic
characteristics.
You start with user needs,
understand position,
understand movement.
Once you've got
that, you can start
to learn climatic patterns,
like everything evolves,
characteristics change,
no one size fits all,
efficiency enables innovation,
higher order systems
create new sources
of value and worth,
past success creates
inertia, economy has cycles,
and you get things like
punctuated equilibriums.
And that enables you
to do amazing acts
of fairly obvious prediction.
This stuff is going
to a utility and it's
going to enable other
stuff to appear.
OK.
Now I get into doctrine because
once you've learned the map
and you start to learn
climatic patterns,
you start to find
universal approaches.
By universal, I mean
they're useful everywhere.
So things like if you're
in a military campaign,
you get things like flanking
movements, which depend
upon where your opponents are.
But there's useful
things like soldiers
learning to shoot a
rifle before a battle.
It's not much use going, oh,
we should flank the opponent.
You better all run
off and start learning
how to shoot a rifle
for the first time.
There is universal stuff
that happens before.
So these are universally
applicable principles,
regardless of context.
So things like,
focus on user needs,
turns out, is
universally useful.
Reduce duplication.
One of the beauties about
maps is, if you share maps--
like immigration, borders
police, UK government-- you
share maps between
departments, you suddenly
start discovering we're building
the same things elsewhere.
Now, I used to think
the government was
bad at duplication
and waste, then
I started looking at
the private sector.
It's amazing.
So I thought really
bad would be having
six examples of the same
system in an organization.
No one would ever beat that.
Then I found a national
bank with 14 CRM systems.
European corporate,
22 rules engines.
I had 118 workflow systems
registering prisoners
into prisons.
We had to do it 118 times.
Then I found a global technology
vendor, 170 Cloud projects all
doing the same thing.
A global pharma company,
300 separate teams
all building enterprise
content management
systems and five global
efforts, none of which
knew the others existed.
A global energy
company, 380 teams
building customized versions
of the same ERP system.
And then I found a bank with
1,000 risk management systems.
And they were all sitting
there going, we can't innovate.
And you just go, I
think I know why.
Anyway, if we take something
like HS2, heavy engineering,
high speed rail.
We used to try and
organize things
with box and wire diagrams.
This is actually a map of them
building the entire railway
in a virtual world because
it is actually much more
sensible to dig up a virtual
world and go, whoops,
we got it wrong, than
in the real world.
But you've got a map and now
what they're do is, we check.
Have we got systems elsewhere?
Are we using the
right sort of method?
We're going to outsource
that stuff on the right,
build off-the-shelf
product-- oh, sorry.
Yeah, use off-the-shelf
products in the middle,
build agile in-house
techniques on the left.
This is 2011, 2012.
Point is, we started using,
now, multiple methods.
That's another form of doctrine,
using appropriate methods.
In the past, we do things
like take out topographical--
sorry.
A box and wire, a
network topology diagram,
and go and ask things
like, should we
outsource this without a map?
And we'd make a decision.
And of course, if you map
that version, what you find
is that some bits are actually
suitable for mapping--
for outsourcing, I should say--
and some bits, on the left-hand
side, are novel and new.
So you wouldn't outsource them.
If you do, you'll just incur
excessive change control costs
because they will
change all the time.
So you don't take a whole
bunch of things like this,
get a big specification
to outsource,
because you will just end
up with huge overruns.
But that's what we'd
done in the past.
And then we'd have
fights with the vendors.
And then somebody, some Muppet,
would come out with the,
well, we need better
specification in the future.
Well, that's never,
ever going to work.
To give you an example of this,
I thought I'd do an experiment.
Do you know what a world
perception server is?
No?
OK.
It's part of a self-driving car.
And what I've done is, I've
translated the network topology
diagram all into Elvish.
So I'm going to pretend
you're all finance.
And IT is all Elvish
to finance people.
So here is the network
diagram in Elvish.
And so I'm going to say,
should we outsource or build
our own A, should we
outsource or build our own B?
What do you think?
This is the sort of decision
processes that we go through.
Anybody?
OK.
What I'm now going to do is I'm
going to convert it into a map.
Exactly the same diagram,
but it's now a map.
Should we outsource
or build our own A?
OK.
Wow.
What about B?
Fantastic.
And of course, now,
translate it back
into English, GPS, and
world perception server.
But the point is, we
make these decisions
about outsourcing
contracts not using--
well, using those
sort of box and wires.
Anyway, you get to
the point of now
you're using
appropriate methods.
And then we get onto
things like FIST,
fast, inexpensive,
simple, and tiny.
US Air Force, Lieutenant
Colonel Dan Ward.
It's an approach of breaking
down large complex systems
into small pieces.
It's used by Special
Operations Command.
What you do is
you've got your map,
you're using the right methods.
Now you think small.
You're building small teams.
Amazon now calls that two-pizza,
Hire has its own cell base
structure.
It's the same thing.
And then what you discover is
that attitudes are different.
So engineering over
here is not the same
as engineering over here,
and it's not the same
as engineering in the middle.
Same with finance and marketing.
So you start building
structures which
cope with evolving attitudes.
You have pioneers,
settlers, and town planners.
And you create, from
that, structures
which are constantly
evolving, cell based,
considering attitude.
We don't have time
to go through that.
But GCHQ, that's our
intelligence services,
very kindly open-source
Boiling Frogs,
which is a document which talks
about how you use structure
around constant change.
OK.
Quick recap.
Strategy cycle.
Purpose, landscap, climate,
doctrine, leadership.
Very basic, very simple.
It's iterative.
It's all about
the why of purpose
and the why of movement.
So observe your environment,
then orientate and decide
in that.
To start with, you
need to have a map.
A map has a number of
basic characteristics,
context-specific, position,
anchor, and movement.
Once you've got
that, you can start
to learn climatic patterns,
things like everything
evolves, characteristics
change, no one size fits all,
efficiency enables innovation,
higher order systems
create new sources of worth.
That we have inertia
caused by past success,
the economy has cycles,
there are things
called punctuated equilibriums.
In fact, what you discover--
prepare yourself for horror--
there are 27 different
common economic patterns.
And so you get to-- it's
like rules of the game.
You get to learn these and
then you can more effectively
anticipate.
And you can just
take your map, you
can describe the likely
points of change,
you can start using weak
signals to refine on that.
Then you get into doctrine.
We now have an idea of what's
in our landscape, where
it's going.
So how do we organize ourselves?
You think about, well, I've
got to focus on user needs.
I'm going to reduce
duplication using multiple maps
between different groups.
Use appropriate
methods, think small,
think aptitude and attitude.
Design for constant evolution.
Prepare yourself for shock.
There's about 40 common
forms of universal doctrine.
Really useful stuff.
Actually, this is quite
useful looking at competitors
because you get an idea
of just how bad they are.
To which people then
go, ah, this is complex.
And it is.
That's why we like stories.
That's why we like
secrets of success.
magic frameworks.
It is complex, I'm afraid.
Then we get into
the leadership bit,
which is all about context
specific forms of gameplay.
So you have your map.
You can anticipate
where things are
going to go because you've
got those climatic patterns.
Not everything is perfect, but
you can do a reasonable job.
And now you're going,
where do I attack?
And this is the why of movement.
Why here over there?
Do I want to build
the first platform,
the first compute environment?
Do I want to modify the
online photo service?
You also learn
where not to attack.
Where to leave it, all the stuff
stuck behind inertia barriers.
And then you start to learn you
can manipulate the environment.
So you can use open
approaches to accelerate,
you can slow things down with
fear, uncertainty, and doubt.
Pattern plays.
There's about four or
five different forms
of ecosystem models.
There's all sorts of constraints
that you can manipulate.
Horror.
There's about 68 different ways
of manipulating the market.
It's great fun.
And so you come up with
a context specific play.
And that's what
we did in Fotango.
2005, we used the map.
We decided to build the world's
first serverless environment.
Platform as a service, or it was
called framework as a service,
originally.
JavaScript front and back end.
You build an entire application.
It had functional billing.
It was all based on JavaScript
operations, network,
and storage.
We anticipated
somebody would play
a utility compute environment.
I actually thought it
was going to be Google.
Didn't realize it was going to
be Amazon the following year
with EC2.
We had a whole open
play around it.
And that's what we went and
did because the next thing is
you act.
So we built and launched Zimki
and it grew like hot cakes.
And we were like, it's great.
People building entire
new applications in a day.
Fabulous.
And then what happened
is the parent company
got some consultants in and
they basically said, oh,
there are three things
that we're doing.
3D printing, mobile
phones as cameras,
and this utility
computing thing.
That's not the future.
The future is 3D TV.
So shut it all down and
spend a billion on 3D TV.
By the way, who owns a 3D TV?
Who uses mobile
phone as a camera?
Who uses Cloud?
3D printers?
I don't like American
strategy consultancy firms.
Anyway.
Anyway, anyway.
So I went to a
company called Ubuntu.
Heard of Ubuntu?
Yay.
So in 2008--
Mark's a friend of mine.
We mapped out the environment,
determined where to attack.
I also mapped out Red
Hat and Microsoft,
and specifically, with Red Hat,
looked for points of inertia
and how we could play
the game against them,
et cetera, et cetera.
Particular things like
where their salesmen
had inertia to change and
how we could exploit that.
So we exploited that, and
basically half a million--
18 months later, we went from
2% operating system market
to 70% of Cloud.
Wee.
That wasn't too bad.
And then I went to
government, wrote something
called the "Better for Less."
Well, sorry.
I worked for a
research organization
called the Leading Edge Forum,
where I did a lot of work
with Liam Maxwell and
with the government.
And this was for Francis
Moore before the coalition
got into power.
So that led to lots of things
like spin control and changes
in the UK government.
So a quick summary.
Strategy's actually
cycle, not a linear path.
It's an iterative process.
It's like chess.
It's a game you have to
learn, it takes time.
It helps to
understand the board.
One of the key things
is, acting movement
is the mechanism of learning.
Really important to understand
the landscape, as well,
to observe it.
So it's all about small steps,
understanding the environment,
being adaptive.
Which is basically
what crossing the river
by feeling the stones, Deng
Xiaoping, is all about.
Now if you're all going,
gah, that mapping, I
don't understand any
of it, don't worry.
It's all Creative Commons.
You'll find
wardleymaps.com has--
I've got a Medium account.
You can read all
about it on there.
And there's a group called Map
Camp setting up to teach people
how to map, as well.
And that's me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Future things to think about.
I had to charge
through all of that
because I just wanted
to get to this point.
I assume-- how many of
you-- actually, I should
have asked that question.
How many of you map?
There's only a few of you.
Hey!
Well, there's some
of you, anyway.
There's three other topics
I can quickly cover.
A serverless ecosystem and MAGA.
That's actually a
spelling mistake.
It should be MAGBA, Make
America Great Britain Again.
Anyway, sorry.
Or quick questions.
Do you want me to
go through these?
Yes?
OK.
So serverless and co-evolution.
Right.
So our platform, really
interesting point of war again.
2014, we're in it.
It's shifting into that
utility space, code execution
environments.
Right.
Let's wind back a little bit,
talk about infrastructure.
So compute.
When compute was a product,
we built applications
which used emerging
architectural practices based
upon compute as a product.
And these were all based
upon the idea of high MTTR.
So I had a server and
if my server went bang,
it would take me weeks
to get a new one.
So I had architectural
practices like scale up,
capacity planning, n+1,
disaster recovery test.
And do you all remember those?
Yes?
Yes.
Great.
Super.
And so they evolved and became
best practice applications
built with best architectural
practice for use
as a server as a product.
And we would mock
people who didn't
do capacity planning and
all that sort of, oh, you
silly person, et cetera.
And then, of course, what
happened is, computer evolved,
became more of a utility.
And so you've got a
new set of emerging
architectural practices based
upon the characteristics which
are low MTTR.
So what happens is
your server goes bang,
takes you seconds to recover.
So you've now got things like
distributed systems designed
for failure chaos engines.
And that evolved and it's
become good practice.
And that's DevOps
and that's legacy.
So when we talk
about legacy, we're
talking about applications
built with best
architectural practice
for product world.
And that is legacy.
And DevOps is applications,
good architectural practice
for utility world.
OK?
And of course, what happens
is, people go, make my legacy
cloudy, i.e., they want to have
all the benefits of efficiency,
agility, and all
that sort of stuff.
So I want to take
that stuff, but I
don't want to re-architect.
And so somebody
sticks their legacy
on something like Amazon.
Amazon has an outage and
they run around going,
the end of cloud is nigh.
To which you go, shouldn't our
architecture evolve, as well?
And they go, burn him.
Evil.
And get her, get her.
A heretic, witch, or
whatever they say.
Right.
So the point is, it's
those people, their best
architectural practice, they
have inertia to this change
and I don't like
this, it's uncertain,
et cetera, et cetera.
Anyway, if you move up
the stack into platform,
we've got this shift going
on from very much a product
space--
I've got a LAMP stack or
whatever it happens to be--
much more to a utility
execution environment.
I just write code, et cetera,
I deal with these functions.
And you'll get a
co-evolution of practice.
So a whole set of new
financial development practices
will come out, particularly
things like functional billing.
It changes the way you operate,
how you invest in things,
refactoring all
this sort of stuff.
And that'll spread.
And so you should be
investing in those two places.
Of course, you're
going to get resistance
from people, best
architectural practice for how
you build LAMP stack of
whatever, legacy environments.
And you're always
going to get resistance
from the DevOps people because
they're now below the line.
So they don't matter as much.
They're going to
become less visible.
And they're not
going to like that.
So they're all going
to give you inertia.
OK.
So you'll go out and say, how
about no Ops, and they're like,
burn you, heretic, and
all the rest of it.
It's tough.
That's the way it goes.
Ecosystem.
If you look at this game, if you
look at somebody like Lambda,
of course there's [INAUDIBLE]
functions and Google Cloud
functions, as well.
Make some noise for it, please.
If you look at
somebody like Lambda,
Amazon is very good at
a particular eco-- well,
it's very good at
ecosystems play.
At this point, I
have to be careful.
Because we cannot say
how they play the game,
but I'll show you an example
of how you might play the game.
So it's a game play called
ILC, innovate, leverage,
commoditize.
It's a decade old.
It's 11 years old, this one.
I know, because I wrote
about it in Zimki.
It's very simple.
You take an activity,
you commoditize it
to a component service,
provide it as a utility.
Everybody builds new things on
top, componentization effects.
They act as your free research
and development department.
Thank you very much.
[? My ?] metadata to identify
new components, which you
provide as utility services.
The group over here grumble, oh,
he's eating my business model.
And that enables new higher
order systems to appear
and everybody thinks
you're brilliant.
And so what you've got is
others innovating for you.
That's your entire ecosystem.
And you're mining metadata
to find future patterns
and you've got an ever-growing
platform of commodity services,
which everybody is building on.
You normally show
it in this form.
You take something
from the ecosystem,
turn it into a utility
service, expose in the API,
everybody builds on top.
Use that to identify
new patterns
by leveraging the data,
metadata, consumption data, not
their actual data.
And then you use it
to build new services.
And the net result,
it's very simple.
Again, it's a very old model.
Your apparent rate of
innovation, customer focus,
and efficiency now all
simultaneously increase
with the size of the ecosystem.
So do you know a
company which seems
to be getting more
innovative, more efficient,
more customer
focused every year,
which other people say, they've
eaten my business model over?
Anybody got any ideas
who that might be?
Right.
So if you are that
company and you're
playing that utility game,
what's going to happen is-- let
us suppose they are
providing a code execution
environment with all those
benefits of functional billing.
Then certainly
soon, you're going
to have a marketplace
with functions
you can buy from others, a
CPAN-like repository where
you can get code
functions from others,
and suddenly, you discover
the level of duplications
in systems is
nothing in comparison
to the level of
duplications within systems,
particularly within code.
And you'll get into a world
where, suddenly, everybody
is building entire
trading applications
in a day and a half.
I know, I built one in two
days, but that was 2006.
So that's the power
of ecosystems.
So really watch out.
Be careful if you discover that
somebody is playing a utility
code execution game against
you with functional billing
and is very good at ecosystems.
Because that's a very dangerous
competitor and somebody
you have to react to.
Right.
MAGBA.
Do you want to hear about MAGBA?
We've only got a
few minutes left.
Right.
MAGBA.
Compared to what?
Make America great
again compared to what?
OK.
Self-driving cars,
because I like
elves and self-driving cars.
I did a piece of work years
ago on the automotive industry.
You start with consumers
want to go from A to B.
They want comfort, affordable.
You've got a pipeline of cars.
They also want
status because they
want to look good in their car.
And underneath that,
you've got things
like entertainment systems,
IS screens, location
based services, IoT, power
supplies, assembly, sensors,
a whole bunch of things.
And what's
interesting, of course,
is that if you roll it
forward, that's 2015--
hm, 2014-- but you roll
it forward to 2025,
you find it's a
lot more commodity
and all that sort of stuff.
Very interesting.
And you find new links.
And what it basically
means is we're
heading into a world
which is all much more
self-driving cars, immersive,
you won't own a car.
You'll have a
digital subscription.
You might have
gold, I might have
silver, which means when I'm
puttering along in my car,
it'll get out of the
way as you zoom past me
and all that sort of stuff.
But it's really exciting.
Not really.
It's all fairly obvious.
From a government point
of view, of course,
it impacts things
like driving licenses
and and you have to think
about that sort of stuff.
But what's interesting
is now, if we start
looking at the points of war--
these points of heavy
industrialization--
and then we start looking
at which governments
are good at investing,
as encouraging industries
prior to those
points of war, you
find China's brilliant
at this stuff.
It's gotten really, really good.
So we all run around going,
the future's Uber, Google,
whatever, within self-driving.
Well, it may be.
But actually, more like
[? DD, ?] et cetera.
So the problem with the whole
"make America great again,"
it's not really
your choice alone.
You are in competition
with other nations.
And if we start looking at the
different value chains and game
play that's going on, there's
some real skilled game play.
You start going, well
actually, there's
some really fierce and capable
and skilled competition.
There's some truly
amazing Chinese companies.
But anyway, people run
around with it and say,
we've got to do this.
And so there's huge obstacles.
And I've been trying to find
what the biggest obstacle is.
And I think it's economic
thought, bizarrely enough.
I took about 160 odd
economists and various people
in the economic field and asked
them a bunch of questions.
So US-centric people,
US-centric economists,
I asked them, on a scale of
centrally planned to laissez
faire, to place a
bunch of economists.
They had Marx, Keynes,
Smith, Hayek, Friedman.
OK?
And they were like, this is the
less effective communist model.
This is the more effective
capitalist model.
And that's how they thought the
US operates, very much Smith,
Hayek, Friedman.
And that's very much
how China operates.
That's interesting
because then I went,
and I kept within
Western philosophy,
and asked a bunch of
European economists
exactly the same question.
What we got is Marx here,
Keynes, Smith, and Hayek
in the middle, Friedman
right on the right.
So they are very
much-- this is more
of a social
capitalist type model.
And that's where the US is.
And this is where China
seems to be operating.
And so you're talking
Europe and the impression
is that China is actually
operating as the world's
largest venture capital firm.
But of course, if
you're talking to people
in this sort of frame, that
doesn't make any sense to them.
So I think part of
the problem is, A,
it's a question of
whether you understand
the actual landscapes
that you're competing in.
What patterns are
actually played?
But it's also the economic
processes of thought.
It's really difficult. You
sit there with US economists
and say, oh, no, it's a VC firm.
They operate like the
world's largest VC
firm, incredibly skilled.
And it's like, people just
have difficulty getting that.
Anyway, it's not
a zero sum game.
The one piece of advice
I actually would have is
there's an awful lot
of learning from China.
There are some really
skilled companies now
who have extended beyond many
of the management practices
we have in the West.
Anyway, that was it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]